Scientists may have just figured out how to
roll back climate change, the only catch?
It could cost as much as 5 trillion dollars
and use more steel than the United States
produces in a year.
Hey there freezing fans, Jules here for Dnews!
Climate change is very real, and one of its
biggest victims is Arctic sea ice.
Since the 1980s, the amount of ice has, on
average, dropped by more than 13 percent each
decade.
But fear not!
Because according to a paper just published
in the journal, Earth’s Future, scientists
may have an ingenious solution.
It involves ten million pumps.
The plan is to “refreeze” ten percent
of the arctic ice cap by using giant wind-powered
pumps to cover the existing caps with salty
seawater..
When the seawater is sprayed on top of frozen
ice and surrounded by the -40 degree celcius
air, it freezes into new ice.
According to the paper, it would take 10 million
wind-powered pumps, outputting roughly 16.5
pounds of water per second, to add 3 feet
of ice over ten percent of the Arctic Ocean.
For every 4 feet of water pumped onto the
surface, the ice will become roughly 3 feet
thicker, a plan that, if it works, will postpone
the loss of the ice caps by about 17 years
for every year they do this.
As the researchers say, quote “Implementation
over the entire Arctic in the early 2030s
… would reset the clock to the present day.”
That’s great news because at the current
rate, scientists estimate the polar ice caps
will be entirely gone by 2030.
Of course, the plan isn’t easy, or economical.
Each wind turbine used to power the pump will
need to be roughly 19 feet across, and use
roughly 22,000 pounds of steel.
The paper also states that ten million pumps
would only really cover ten percent of the
Arctic Ocean’s roughly 4 million square
mile size; to cover the entire area would
take 100 million pumps, and roughly 100 million
tons of steel each year.
The US alone currently produces about 80 to
90 million tons of steel a year, so covering
just 10 percent of the Arctic ice would use
around 13 percent of U.S. steel production.
The total cost would be 50 billion dollars
per year, or 500 billion over 10 years -- and
again, that’s if you only cover 10 percent
of the Arctic.
To cover the whole thing would be a whopping
5 trillion dollars.
But not all efforts to save the Arctic ice
caps are so costly.
Another leading solution is called solar-radiation
management, where sunlight is reflected away
from the ice, instead of being absorbed by
it, leading to slower melting.
One method of doing this is to inject reflective
aerosol particles, particularly chemicals
like sulfates, into the stratosphere.
In nature, volcanic eruptions scatter sulfate
particles high into the air as part of an
ash cloud, and it has been observed that these
particles reflect solar radiation back into
space and lead to cooling of the earth below
it.
So if we could do this artificially, it could
have the same effect.
In fact, a 2008 study found that if we could
decrease the sunlight reaching the Arctic
area by about 21%, it would allow the ice
to remain even if the amount of CO2 in the
air doubled.
But this solution leads to many other environmental
concerns, such degradation of the ozone, which
sulfates are known to do.
It could also lead to a warming of the stratosphere,
as the reflective particles would absorb some
of the heat and disperse it in the surrounding
atmospheric air.
Both of these could ultimately lead to a worsening
of climate change conditions.
And the aerosol in itself is air pollution,
of the kind that leads to asthma and other
health problems.
Ultimately, there is no simple, elegant solution.
The paper itself admits that technology alone
won’t solve our problems.
The world is still warming, the ice caps are
melting, and the sea levels are rising.
Without the ice caps reflecting light away
from earth, the ocean will absorb even more
solar radiation and heat, which could influence
global warming.
Worse yet, the more ice is melted in the Arctic,
the more methane, a greenhouse gas, will be
released into the atmosphere.
Currently that methane is trapped under the
permafrost, and as that thaws, it could speed
up the effects of global warming.
While setting up 100 million pumps, or shooting
sulfates into the sky may sound crazy, those
may not be as crazy as the alternatives.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code DNEWS at checkout.